cheers everybody to wally's wine and
spirits first annual tequila and mezcal
festival you are dressed for the part i
feel a little underdressed right now i
need to need a hot need to you know look
like i'm having a tequila chilling well
you're gonna right now you are that's
the first thing i know now you've hosted
these events in new york la hawaii and
beyond and now we have christian navarro
who is the president and principal of
wally's and you're here to tell us how
we're doing it
vegas style well vegas though you know
it's the best style you know i'm saying
and we're at resorts world yes in las
vegas it's amazing what they have is
this incredible rose roof top you can
see all the way down the strip there's
going to be mariachis there's going to
be food there's going to be tequila it's
going to be a heck of a party wow okay
so just explain the concept though it's
a tequila mezcal festival so what are we
doing exactly besides drinking
i i think that is the purpose right
right we're gonna be trying mexican food
okay we're gonna be drinking tequila and
mezcal trying all the best from around
the world okay 150 different ones wow
we're going to be testing them it's
going to be a beautiful weekend right
we're going to have a great time you
meet a bunch of new people i love that
that's perfect now let's get into the
drink let's get into the drink what are
we drinking exactly is this tequila or
mezcal this is tequila el cristiano
tequila it's amazing no additives that
means they squeeze the juice they make
the tequila and that's it
so we're going to make a skinny
margarita okay cristiano sauce
a little bit of tequila you're gonna
squeeze the lemon lime and orange okay
and that's the drink it's simple simple
that's perfect and what's the difference
between the tequila and the mezcal well
tequila and mezcal are basically the
same thing
except you smoke them as cow so it gives
you that smoky flavor okay so kind of an
acquired taste though right it's an
acquired taste but once you acquire it
you never leave it no there you go
so squeeze so now i'm squeezing is there
what what goes first
technique it's just whatever i want to
do come on all right i'm gonna go lemon
first okay
that's for you mercedes and your lemon
dress
what a dress i'm gonna go
orange
for you for me no am i okay i'm
squeezing that's right that's good a
little messy i'm gonna do this you need
a little lime it's kind of sour just
like me oh
sweet
okay boom
lovely there we go cheers cheers now
warn me how strong is this
it's only as strong as you want it to be
just take a little sip
right all right while i take a sip tell
people how they can get tickets and join
you guys
you can go online wallywine.com
or you can go onto the resorts world
website which is amazing and if you're
it's a hundred bucks but if you're local
you get twenty percent off oh my gosh
and i don't have the exact website or
connection there it's lv
uh something something don't worry you
get a discount we got you we got we
already are coming up we
this is good i'm not typically you know
a tequila mezcal kind of gal it's the
most healthy beverage you could ever
have yeah i'm here for okay all right
here we go
cheers to the festival you guys wally's
wine and spirits first annual tequila
and mezcal it's happening this saturday
at resorts world that rose rooftop
sounds fabulous nevada locals you will
receive a 20 discount when you purchase
your tickets and the code is lv locals
20 upon checkout mercedes i'll send to
you